On April 25th, Destiny gave an affidavit. All right. He he signed
an affidavit. He submitted that. Okay. Declaration of Steven
K. Benell. Now, I believe this is pursuant to 28 USC 1746, which
is it's still a statement under penalty of perjury. Okay. We
go down here. We go to paragraph 14 and 15. So, if you've been
unaware, if you haven't been keeping up with the case, uh, Null,
the owner of Kiwi Farms, basically said, uh, yeah, you know,
we'll we'll comply with any subpoenas that not subpoenas, we'll
comply with I'm sure they would comply with subpoenas, but like
if people want to take stuff down, we would want a court order.
Okay, so Pixie's legal team went and got a court order, and I
believe the video got taken down or something. Okay, I think
they got some data from them, too. I didn't really look into
that that much. But the very interesting thing was null decided
he was going to comment because somebody pointed this out. Okay.
In or about the first week of December 2024, I retain specialized
legal counsel. This is Destiny's affidavit. Somebody pointed
this out. 2024, Destiny says, "I retain specialized legal counsel
with expertise in revenge matters to assist me in connection
with having my explicit content, including the video I made with
the plaintiff removed from the internet." Uh, Gringle TV, thank
you for resubing. Appreciate it, dude. Appreciate you. Okay.
Thereafter, Plaintiff and I communicated about my efforts to
have that content, including our video, removed from any website
on which it was unlawfully published. I provided plaintiff with
updates on my progress with respect to the removal efforts by
me and my attorneys. Plaintiff also had the ability to legal
and the ability and legal right to seek the removal of the video
from the online platforms on which it was hosted. However, I
am not aware of any efforts that the plaintiff made to have the
video removed from any site, including Kiwi Farms. So, now, can
we point out an explicit lie here? I actually don't know. I actually
I don't know if we could point out a very explicit lie here,
okay? Because he doesn't really claim to have done anything other
than engage legal counsel. And it was funny because Nell decided
to go ahead and post, you know, you know, hey Null, what did
you get for for communication from Destiny's legal counsel? Well,
apparently the only email he got from Destiny was this one. Revenge
removal request. All it says is, "Hi there. There's been revenge
myself posted on your website. Please remove it as soon as possible.
Link. Thanks." So, basically, somebody asked if he's able. That's
That's it, right? That's it. And I'm looking at this and I'm
like, "Oh, yeah." But he means like he got his lawyers to look
into it, right? He got his his lawyers to look into it. Null
says, "I did not find this particularly persuasive." You don't
know. Okay. If you don't know, Kiwi Farm's usually resistant
to legal threats. Okay? You got to actually get the law involved
in some way to get them to do stuff. All right? So, that's the
only communication he has this alone. All right. Again, in his
in his sworn affidavit, not sworn affidavit under penalty of
perjury. Okay. Statement under penalty of perjury. He seems to
have said that he made progress or he did some things. Now, maybe
there are like other sites he went to or and maybe I I don't
know, but I would love to know what efforts were undertaken specifically
because he cites this. He provides no evidence for it. And then
the evidence we have from the owner of Kiwi Farms where this
stuff was infamously kind of launched, right, is this one request
right here. So, I I I'm baffled by a few things. Who are the
specialized legal counsel precisely? And then why is it that
null followed this up by also announcing, "Yeah, I did not receive
any attorney communication until those lawyers physically mailed
Harden." So I don't know that this is their host or something,
but basically Pixie's lawyers actually sent physical mail to
null and he got no other communications at all, he says. So where
where were these specialized lawyers in in revenge removal and
why did they not do so far as we could tell anything? You have
the other talk where he compliments Pixie's attorney. I don't
know what you're talking about, Riyle. But Harden is their law
firm. Oh, right. Sure. I missed that. My bad. I just thought
this was really interesting and funny to be honest with you.
Uh, okay. All right. So, we went from here to there's a streamable
R gave me. Oh, I also Oh, Kelly can't be here. I told Kelly we
were doing uh other stuff today. I told her we're doing all kinds
of other stuff and then I immediately went into Destiny stuff.
So, now I feel a little bad. I should have said, "Hey, I'm going
to do Destiny stuff real quick." Oh well. Oh well. Oh well. Okay.
Okay, it's fine. It's fine. It'll be fine. So, this to me, I
wrote up a tweet on this last night and I didn't know how to
phrase it exactly, but I would just love for Desi's to like point
out exactly how he tried to do this because this ties into Pixie's
legal team basically, I believe, getting a court order to compel
Kiwi Farms to take the video of her down. Okay. And Destiny had
some comments on that. Oh, yeah. So, this was a this is I think
a prelude screenshot here. Null also says, "We've been in contact
with Ms. do's legal team for a while and they're being pretty
reasonable. So, we indicated we don't intend to object to any
of their requests. However, we insisted on them getting a court
order. Cool. So, apparently it seems like Destiny may have suggested,
"Hey, if you guys are talking to Kiwi Farms, why don't you get
like all of the videos taken down?" Which is a really, really
weird request in my opinion. I think that's a weird request.
Now, Ry made a streamable for me. I actually haven't seen this
yet, so I don't know. We'll we'll take a look at this. Okay.
I can't wait for this thing to be over so I can talk a little
bit more candidly about everything. But these are Is he not speaking
candidly? He's literally like slandering victims consistently,
leaking DMs with them and Is this not him speaking candidly?
How much more candid can he possibly be? What l Where's the lack
of cander? I don't see it. Where is it? I don't get it. I don't
see it. It's very odd to me. Publicly filed. Now, this is probably
some of the like most I think disgusting behavior that I think
I've ever been subjected to, I think, in my entire life. The
most man, he really is that that's just crazy. He's like the
real victim here again, guys. The actual victim right here. Right
here. This is the most disgusting behavior. The most disgusting.
Oh, so is he going to is he going to start toxing more people?
Cuz I thought I thought me and Quan covering his legal case was
already the most disgusting he'd ever seen. It turns out every
day this is the most disgusting day of this guy's life. Okay,
it's actually on. But so they have a proposed order for the court.
They sent us this one ahead of time so we can talk about it.
They're looking for a court order to compel LCAL LLC to remove
videos. Kiwi Farms comes now plaintiff Jane Doe buy and through
undersigned council and respectfully requests that the court
enter an agreed proposed order to compel law. Wow. Did they do
this unilaterally? LLC, which I'm guessing is the probably the
business entity of Joshua of Kiwi Farms or whatever. Kiwi Farms
to remove specified URLs that link to the video and for the imposition
of costs and attorney fees on defendant as follows, which is
me. So, they want me to pay for this somehow. Okay. Yeah, but
for your leaking of this video to a random 19-year-old, that
video wouldn't be there. Yeah, you should at minimum you should
pay legal fees.
Which, by the way, didn't he wasn't it very obvious from the
beginning that he I thought he was telling everybody, "Yeah,
of course I'll cover like getting this stuff removed." what a
ongoing efforts to have the video removed from the multiple different
platforms on which it was published including the Kiwi Farms
platform. Kiwi Farms is managed and operated by Loca LLC. The
video was originally published on Kiwi Farms on November 29th,
2024 on February 20th, 2025, 2 days after the complaint in this
action was filed. The custodian of records of Kiwi Farms removed
the original post of the video and replaced it with the following
message. Um, I don't think it was removed. I think they just
made us here to be logged in to actually to actually see the
I think but I don't logged in. I was letting him read. I was
letting him read and I wasn't reading myself. Ongoing efforts
to have the video removed. So on February 20, 2025, two days
after the complaint in the action was filed, the custodian of
recorders Kiwi Farms removed the original post the original post
of the video and replace it with the following message. Uh Kiwi
Farms is managed and operated by Loca LLC. The video was originally
published on Kiwi Farms on the other. They just made us here
to be logged in to actually to actually see the I think but I
don't even have my account so I don't know but I think that's
what it says here. So they repost Joshua's full statement. Although
the original post which included the link to the video was removed
by QB Farms. The video resurfaced in multiple other posts on
QB farms. Plaintiff had a subpoena served on LCL LLC on May 10th,
2025. The subpoena requested the production of certain documents
and also the removal of the links to the video depicting plaintiff.
LEL LLC/Kew farms has cooperated with plaintiff's request to
produce documents and has expressed its willing to remove all
specified URLs which link to the video upon receipt of an order
from this court. Loel LLC has reviewed the proposed order attached
here to in redacted form as exhibit A and has stated that it
will not object. Okay. The all specified URLs which link to the
video upon receipt of an order from the court. So the video so
Pixie's video. Okay. And will comply once the order is entered
by the court. Plaintiff is simultaneously filing a motion for
leave to file under seal uh the unredacted proposed order. Oh,
good job. They learned how to do this. Which contains the specific
URLs that link to the video. Pursuant to the local rules, plaintiff
met and conferred with the defendant regarding the instant motion.
Defendant does not object to the entry of the proposed order
to compel LCL LLC to remove the videos. Um, I don't know if we're
100%. Maybe plaintiff also request Oh, ple by by all means, Essie,
please, please object to Pixie having her video removed because
you're a spiteful [__] Please, please do that. Just
show the world who you are.
By the way, I'll tell you exactly what that means. We aren't
sure on this. His lawyers told him it would it would be the worst
thing for us optically in the world. We would look so bad in
front of any jury ever if we oppose this. And he's like, "I still
kind of want you to do it." Right? That's 100% what's happening
there. His lawyers, Andrew Breler, has been the whole time been
like, "Hey, we shouldn't we shouldn't oppose like her filing
anonymous. We shouldn't oppose this." And Destiny does want to
he wants to make this as painful as possible, right? And Andy
B, the guy who defended Prince Andrew, is sitting there like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You're maybe the most disgusting client I've ever had, but let's
chill. I'm going to control you a little bit here and we're going
to make sure we get through this lawsuit. Attorney's fees and
related cost pursuant to 15 USC 1651 incred as a direct result
of defendant unlawful disclosure of the video. A direct like
did I post it on as in a direct causal result? Yes, a direct
causal result here. But okay, whatever. Plaintiff's expenses
include legal and professional services necessary to pursue removal
of the unlawful content from Kiwi Farms. So, writing that seems
reasonable. The defendant has avert efforts to remove the unlawful
content. He has provided no evidence of such efforts and has
not succeeded in having any content removed. I mean neither of
you guys. I feel like was it in my filings in here? Didn't I
show screenshots of me like working with plaintiff to report
stuff? I feel like I Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Did he Did he report stuff? I would love
to see. I think Okay, hold on. I saw this. I need to go find
these images really quickly as we put this together. Okay, he
says he posted images. I've seen these logs. Let me find them
real quick.
Let me find them. Let me find them. Let me find them. Not this
one here. We We can keep listening for just a second. No, you'll
listen to my voice, actually. Here they are. Here they are.
So, hi. One more question. Are you going to try and get the threads
removed or not for revenge? I'm looking into it. Yeah, but the
way from no the way null phrases it on the site, you need a court
order because he probably doesn't ever want to remove stuff like
that. Z. So, I'm getting in contact with a law firm to see if
it's even possible. When will you be in contact with that law
firm?
Oh, when will you be in contact with that law firm? Not sure.
I'll know by tomorrow. Nino is supposed to be contacting them.
Wow, there are some other people under the bus.
Okay, hold on. Sounds good. Do you think you'll try to go criminally
after the person or not? I assume you can subpoena Kiwi Farms
for his account information and maybe even IP address and go
from there if you desire. Or do you feel like that would be too
much attention to draw to draw to it? I have absolutely no idea.
Waiting for those law firm to confirm a call with me. I think
also like I said, I wouldn't won't do anything in terms of filing
civil stuff or making criminal complaints without checking with
you first. Okay. And then 6 days later, after no updates at all,
Pixie Pixie messages him apparently and says, "Any updates on
getting it removed from KW Farms. Working on a second law firm
now have a PI investigating to figure out who the person is so
I can get an injunction against them. But the first one doesn't
didn't seem very helpful. So apparently he was looking for a
second law firm and trying to get this taken down. Apparently
JC, this message is from the same date that he sent null the
email. So he probably did not have the law firm at the time he
sent the request to null. Null probably told him to get a court
order or off. Maybe
could be. I don't I don't know if uh I don't know if null even
replied, but that would be interesting to know. In any case,
I do find it interesting that Destiny had a PI investigating.
I would love I would love if he could just post, you know, the
receipts from this. Did we find the solo guy? The person who
the person who leaked it? He apparently had a private investigator.
What did the private investigator find?
I'm I'm very curious.
Anyway, at J. Go to the other Discord. Okay, hold on, Kelly.
I'll move.
Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Yeah, I needed to spend at least
a minute being like, how entitled do you have to be to assume
that a lawyer would do free work removing tapes for you that
had nothing to do with the plaintiff? We Hold on. You're spoiling.
We haven't gotten there in the video yet, Kelly. Chill. Chill.
We'll get there. We'll get there. Okay. Sorry. Wait, what did
you What did you show? Because he just said it was pretty much
everything. But it's fine. I think we all know. I think we all
know
today was like the most disgusting thing he's ever happened.
Yeah, but he hadn't gotten into it yet. It's okay. It's okay.
We're like two seconds away from it. It's not a big deal.
Act to mitigate ongoing harm. The defendant should bear the cost
of that mitigation. Wherefore, plaintiff respectively request
course order locator remove specific URLs blah blah blah. Okay.
So, I would object to some of the wording in here, but like on
its face, on its face, this is a it's fine. So, wow. My suggestion
was a so he basically told Pixie already that he paid a legal
firm to attempt this, right? That's what he that that is what
he intimated to Pixie and intimated to through his affidavit.
Now, it doesn't say in there that I instructed them to bill me
for removal from Kiwi Farms. So, there's some wiggle room there,
but holy, if listen, if we want to do like a court order to take
stuff down, like why don't we do a court order to take down like
all of the explicit material? And they said, "No, not unless
you pay us money." And I'm like, "That makes total sense." There's
actually a couple reasons that make sense, but let's see if he's
capable of thinking of any of them beyond his own victimhood.
Really? Let's see. Let's see. And then they're asking for us
to cover the by pay money like pay whatever the attorney's fees
are. And I was like, seriously? It's actually unreal. So they
were like, oh, just pay us the fees that it would cost to do
so and we will. Does he understand that he should be a shouldn't
he be able to do this through his own law firm? What to me? But
whatever, I guess. Like good times. There's no way. Hold on.
I don't think we're opposing this moisture to order, but hold
on. I got a really worried about the material standing up. Uh,
well, they only want to remove just the videos involving plaintiff.
That's it. But they don't care about anything else, including
the other people. Can anybody explain to me over and over again,
I guess. But hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I don't I
don't actually understand. I actually I actually totally don't
understand here. Wait. Can a judge in a civil case make an order
to compel somebody to take down content that is in no way related
to that case? Because I could have sworn that Desty's entire
argument this entire time is every single other revenge video
that's on there and any any witnesses who come forward and talk
about them that that's totally unrelated and totally random.
So, how does the court have the ability to compel Kiwi Farms
or anywhere else to take down those totally unrelated and totally
random videos?
Can I I'm now hyper confused. Can somebody explain that? I mean,
null has said that the only like take down quotation he's got
from Destiny's side is a singular email 6 months ago or some
Right. There was no court order from his side. Yeah. But I'm
saying he wants he wants to basically have Pixie get all of the
material taken down and they said just pay for the they said
they would try you pay for the legal fees, which is by the way
a totally reasonable thing to say. Okay. But but I just I his
entire time he's like those those other victims they're totally
unrelated and totally random. Those other people it's all unrelated
and now it's like okay but now they should get all the other
videos taken down that from those same victims that are totally
random. Yeah. Apparently lawyers do charity work for Destiny
now. And not doing charity work for Destiny makes you disgusting
apparently. Questionable.
A court probably can't do it. Well, a court did do a vigilance
stream as far as I know. Did they Did they not? I thought a court
order came through, unless I'm mistaken. Maybe this is just uh
maybe this is just the proposal, though. It probably is just
the proposal, right? Cuz it's a motion.
Kiwi Farm said that he'd been talking to Pixie side for longer
and that he'd been complying with them. It's just that they require
like a court order. Hold on. Let's see what he said precisely
here. Did he say he did did not receive any attorney communication
till those lawyers physically mailed Harden? So the uh
okay so I I actually don't know this doesn't necessarily mean
he hasn't been in contact with them at all but
really hasn't been a priority. I think that's safe to say. At
Jto, how is it fair? They are in a legal twist where Pixie went
public and put everything out there. Pixie did not go public.
In fact, Pixie did not go public. Somebody else went public with
the story before Pixie did and it was blowing up on Twitter,
right? Do we not remember? Do wait, you understand that there
were things published before the Substack, right?
Do we not understand that the Sunday and Becca videos got published
before that? Or is this person have like holes in their brain?
What I'm confused about is what Destiny is supposedly helping
with. If he's paying for his revenge that he sent to someone
who then leaked it, why wouldn't he pay for it? I don't That's
a good question, too. Yes. Destiny is being fat and cheap again.
Yet again, cheap, fat, fat, cheapy, cheap, fatty. Shocking. So,
I'd love to know exactly what actions were taken by his law firm
that he was telling Pixie about, you know, that that apparently
they were going to do stuff. I just I would love to. And then
his affidavit got a law firm that specializes in this that I
would just love to see even the buildings from that law firm.
Like basically, you should get a you should get like a build
that says exactly what they build you for, right? To have takedowns,
I would imagine. I would imagine, but who knows? Okay, hold on.
There was more here. Let me just go look. I wasn't going to cover
I didn't even know about some of this other stuff. I don't know
about the video. Oh, right. The logs. Sure.
Hold on. Let me see here.
So, let me Oh, this is Wait, wait, wait, wait. Open this like
this. Is this better? Is this not better? This still sh Whatever.
Whatever. Destiny Abby is threatening Darius with your current
lawsuit. I have no idea what this is. Maybe this is leaks or
something. Leaked Abby is trying to blackmail him with a lawsuit.
I don't know what that is about. I guess I we might have to look
at some of the logs from whatever this stream was at some point.
Although, I will say it's very odd that Destiny keeps leaking
logs that have to do with another person. It's very strange.
But someone DM me in four years when they finally start reading
these. Holy [__] Who is the guy in here that sounds
exactly like Jtock? Holy. Oh, Legacy. Cool. He is haunted. He
is actually just eternally haunted. It's very funny. Okay. So,
she keeps commenting, "This is an actual midnight hour witness
they brought in to make sure the complaint survived." Uh, I'm
I'm pretty confident. Like, then you should just be able to file
some stuff that shows that she's actually been in contact with
them. She gave them like an affidavit before this and they waited
to file it. I just don't believe that's the case. It doesn't
make any sense at times.
Oh, yeah. Man, there's a couple things going on that just make
no sense to me. He He's got like the weirdest double-sided logic
here. Oh, by the way, that guy who was talking in chat absolutely
just ran the second he was shown to be a That's crazy. Anyway,
I just find that funny. So, I think the argument though is that
she's not testifying to a true thing. Either lying or misrepresenting.
What is this about fighter? She claimed in her affidavit she
has logs. Well, she said she had proof she talked to you, but
she didn't have links to the video. And then she had proof that
she had told friends about it. Right. Do we have to go and look
at the Abby affidavit? I could have sworn it was logs of talking
to Destiny and then am I crazy? I was talking to a friend as
well. She said she had logs of talking to a friend that she talked
to a friend that mentioned like names or something. Just give
me a second to go look. Go take a look. Oh my god, there's a
lot of things filed in this case, you know. Crazy coincidental
to be talking to a friend like at exactly that time about tapes
that Destiny had sent you and we didn't find out it even existed.
I know find out existed until way later on. So I messaged a friend
of mine and told him Destiny had sent me the above se mentions
explicit video of himself and another woman and then I recognized
the other woman as a streamer pixie blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah. Sorry I'm not going to say names of people
who don't want to be mentioned with regards to the suit. So she
retained possession of copy of the messages to my friend through
my relationship with Destiny repeatedly shared me explicit videos
of himself and other women shared through Google Drive links.
I know that these women have most likely never consented to their
private videos being shared. Uh, I recently reviewed my Discord
account and realized Destiny had deleted all direct messages
to me onto the Discord platform, including the sharing of the
P video Pixie. I retained copies of all my messages to Destiny
as well as my messages to other people about his non-consensually
non-consensual sharing of explicit videos. I do not want to have
my publicly identified uh public identity publicly revealed since
I have recently discovered that Destiny shared some explicit
videos of himself and me with other people without my consent
just like he did to Pixie and these other women. Okay. Well,
so it sounds like she has her messages to Destiny. Yes. And then
her messages to friends. So, let me see here. Where were we talking
about logs? She claimed in her affidavit she has logs. She did
not. She said she had logs where she talks about it with others,
not even the actual logs of her with you. No, she said she has
logs talking to me as well. It was in the affidavit. Yes, logs
talking to you. Yes. True. Okay. All right, cool. Uh, shouldn't
there be an adjudication that he is liable before he has to pay
attorneys fees for something like this, though? Well, I I assume
this motion would be the motion is just suggesting it, right?
I I assume this is a motion. No. Yeah, proposed order. So, I
would assume that with this motion that if it's unopposed, he
will have to pay them. He could just oppose this on the grounds
that he doesn't want to pay though, right? Absolutely. I'm pretty
sure he's cheap, so I would expect that. Can you say for the
record account and posted in that thread? Not sure why he lied
about that. Wait, what did he say about that pensive goat? Did
he say he didn't have a an account? Sorry. Go ahead, Kelly. I
forgot. Okay. She
forgore. Okay, dude. What the How do we get the We got running
in the '9s synth wave remix. That's crazy. Oh, that's what I
was going to say. How is he going to explain not getting all
of the other tapes down if he doesn't pay? Like I don't He looks
like so bad to all of the cuz he's getting sued from other people
too, right? As far as I'm aware. Oh, well, there's apparently
an Abby lawsuit. Sure. I think they just made it so you need
an account, but I wouldn't know cuz I don't have a KF account.
Oh, he does have a KF account. I don't know if this is him on
stream though, so he can just lie on stream obviously. Yeah,
I just thought it was very interesting. Guys, just very He's
lying about that account not being his. Well, he's just I mean
he's just saying he doesn't have a calf account, which he obviously
does. Maybe he's forgetting. Yeah. What the more Alzheimer's
today? Jesus. Okay. I don't have an account account named Destiny.
That is Destiny. Yeah. Okay. Does he forget that he like spoke
to null on his stream two years ago as well? I mean, and there's
stream clips of him saying uh there are stream clips of him literally
talking about having an account. So, Zoe apparently sent me another
link. What is this? Says it here. Oh, is she just sending me
the Yeah, I don't I don't doubt that this happened, guys. I I
literally I don't doubt that this hap that he has an account
and that he lied about it. But like it's this is like a lie where
it's like he's probably just used to speaking this way. Uh if
you clarified, he'd probably just say remove the original post
of the video and replace it with the following message. I don't
think it was removed. I think they just made us here to be logged
in to actually to actually see the I think. But I don't even
have my account, so I don't know. But I think that's what so
I think based on something that null did say it seemed like he
was saying that he they tried to give data to Pixie but one of
the pieces of data didn't exist anymore because it's gone past
the retention limit or something. Okay. So he deleted it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I just assume from Null's comment where it
was like one of one piece of data she asked for we couldn't give
her because it was like past our retention limit or something.
I assume that's Destiny deleting his account and not wanting
to have his IP like them not having the IPs anymore or something.
Uh, right-wing lunatic, you're funny calling that bad faith,
though. Someone, anyone see anything about a lady getting shot
outside of the CIA today? No. What? Yesterday? No. But we did
see the thing about the two Israeli uh diplomats getting shot.
We might check that out. Can't delete Kiwi Farm accounts. Is
that true? Maybe. I have no idea. Okay. Yeah. I don't know. There's
I might have other points I need to make, but I I just figured
we'd do that real quick cuz it's very goofy. Oh, the other thing
that still exists. Well, there you go. Hey, the other thing that's
almost as bad as this whole thing where he uh where he explicitly
talks about how where he explicitly says, "Oh, they aren't taking
my other videos down. That's so crazy when he basically when
it when it's him who's the victim in his mind. All of these things
are related, right? And the court has power to affect them."
And then in another case where he says, "Joto, yeah, I threatened
Jay-T. He's not related to the case at all." But I also realized
he's also talked about subpoenaing me with respect to this case.
Apparently, he's somehow subpoenaed some logs related to me.
How can How can he subpoena somebody unrelated to the case? Why?
Where's his like probable cause for any of that? Where where
is any of that coming from? I'm unrelated to the case, but he's
going to subpoena me for logs or subpoena logs that involve me.
How? How? And why? If I'm unrelated, is that not him explicitly
making me related? Like he himself making me related, you're
going to get exposed for witness tampering and go to jail. Okay.
I just I find that very funny. Like this guy has no consistency
whatsoever. It's just very embarrassing for basically anyone
who tries to watch him, I would assume. Uh my Kickat just entirely
disappeared. Hello. Maybe he should ask the court to take down
the videos. Well, yeah. If the court even has the power, he should
be able to do it, shouldn't he? Shouldn't he be able to request
through this case for those videos to get taken down? But apparently
not. Wow. I just got to link this. Cool. Very cool. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Very cool. Okay. Is there anything else I missed here? I
don't think so. I just I don't understand why. Why would he not
agree to pay the lawyer's fees to get them to try to do everything
that doesn't I don't I don't understand. I literally don't have
any idea. I'm very lost. Okay. Well, that was the quick Destiny
update. That's it. That's all. I think that is all. That's it.
That's everything. Hold on. Hold on. Riyle says we need to hold
on. Are we holding on? Null from Kiwi Farms has more respect
than Destiny. He says Ms. Do Oh, true. That is actually very
true. Wow. It doesn't seem like Kiwi Farms last for much. If
it just requires like a a court filing court or didn't do that
pretty
bars did they did the team the legal team that he constantly
criticizes for being terrible. Yeah. And how long did it take
them to do it? Uh how long did it take Pixie team? I actually
don't know. No idea. Because he's desperate for Pixie to run
out of money. He will never contribute in any way that helps
her pay for her lawyers. That's really what it is. Major Dr.
Gastley. and he's trying to paint it as like some kind of win
for himself, but it's very embarrassing, right? He clearly is
like that's he's hoping she'll run out of money so these people
stop representing her, but he also seems to just lie randomly
about Yeah, he seems to just lie randomly and say that Pixie
is also getting this covered pro bono, which I don't I don't
know. I say lie, I just don't know like where is that information
coming from? Oh, last thing that I wanted to point out which
was from those logs which I've moved away from. Hold on. I set
those logs up. Where are they? It's all right. It was like uh
not these ones. It was these ones. This one? No. God, I'm out
of sorts today, guys. Not that one. Not that one. Not that one.
Not that one. Oh, it's the one with the private investigator.
I wonder why. I just wonder what this PI firm found that he decided
to drop this case. You know what I'm saying? What exactly? What
exactly did we find here that we decided to just, you know, stop
looking? Oh, somebody's age is probably Yes, they found the child.
Exactly. They f they found the CSA victim. Okay, that's that
seems to be most likely what happened. I just look forward like
honestly that actually if we're being honest, if if that person
is a child, it probably makes this like significantly worse.
But there is some at least silver lining in that we can literally
call Destiny a and we can literally say that Destiny has bought
child. That would be very funny. Okay. I just think that would
be very funny to be able to say that and then not worry about
uh since he is a very latigious fellow, not worry about getting
sued for defamation. That would be super funny. The second one
the second one is just objectively true. They're under 18 and
making a boy's child. Yeah. Exactly. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Anyway,
he paid for it. VX77. He paid for it. Absolutely. He literally
he literally did pay for it. won't pay for lawyer to issue a
court order. Will pay for child. Makes sense.
All right, I think that's it. Sorry, we pulled that together
last second. It's weird that he comes and like participates directly
in like so I think they did a Darius stream last night where
they were like explicitly attempting to make Abby look worse,
right? Who's a witness and somebody who's suing Destiny and then
Destiny comes into this stream into DGG chat and starts commenting
on that stream driving traffic to it. Like to me that seems like
it would also be kind of suspicious, kind of weird, kind of out
of bounds. You know what I mean? Like it's a it's literally a
stream for the purpose of making this person look worse and then
he's funneling people towards it. Hold on. Ry Riyle wants me
to look at them talking about this. We'll see. Who's them? Darius's
stream talking about some with me. Slander hours. Yeah, I don't
It seems like like isn't that too direct a link to really be
uh Golem 86. That's true. But I'm just saying that probably if
you're in a lawsuit against them, this probably getting on the
line and when they're a when they're a literal um like witness
against you, which is probably weird. I don't know. I would assume.
Anyway, I'm just waiting on a link here. We'll see if we're going
to go do this to include it in the segment here.
Anyway, this guy's a this guy's just such a loser. Knows we didn't
actually finish this. Hold on. We'll see if uh there's more.
Why did you file it in your case? Who the knows?
Does the judge react to this? No, but we have a hearing on the
6th or the fourth or third or something. I don't know. We have
a hearing in a couple weeks, thankfully. So,
what is this? I literally have no idea. People just linked it
like 20 times that it was epic memes.
But actually, now that you bring up the fact that they want us
to pay for their fees, maybe we do oppose this motion. I'm not
sure actually. I don't know if we've talked that much about it.
He signed an affidavit saying he literally sent this to another
person, right? the person whose account was was eventually used
to leak all this material. Like, he is responsible for it. He
has no explicit consent. I don't even know why you would possibly
oppose the lawyer's fees. He's the person who violated her trust.
He literally says in his messages to other people, I violated
her trust in the most egregious of ways. Like Ironically, Destiny
talks about misily. Yes. Ironically, Destiny talks about how
this is court and you can't make Reddit arguments. Yet all the
ways he likes to discredit women every time he wrongs them would
also be invisible character evidence. Exactly. Yes. But of course,
Vigilant Stream, you are only operating on level one. The entire
reason he does this is he wants to harass them. He wants to create
like an environment where they can't exist on the internet as
well, right? He wants to create as much harassment for them as
he possibly can to get them to go, "Okay, actually, I don't want
to participate anymore. Let me drop out. Let me get out of here."
Right? That's his goal. explicitly his goal. Obviously his goal.
That's the thing he's looking to do. He still doesn't cop up
all the framing and it's uh peopleing themselves to take him
down. Well, technically he did sign the affidavit saying he did
the thing. It's just he said he did it before the uh before Kappa.
It's not Kappa. God, no. Ah, party. Jesus Christ. Oh man. I don't
know. I If it's not anything to do with me. Yeah. I just I feel
like gross platforming them being Can you talk about Darius?
Yeah. I I linked a time stamp where they're going to talk a bunch
of It's going to make my brain hurt again. What do we do, Kelly?
What do we do? By the way, we're just we're going to Amaran stuff
after this, depending on if we're going to watch this or not.
Yeah. Yeah, I know. I get it. Is it just Darius talking? Uh,
no. It's Darius and like a panel of or something. Oh, we can
try. It's terrible and it's fine. Uh, I will just remind everybody,
okay, if if anything we hear about Abby and and how Abby is bad
in some way from these whatever we hear from them, uh, we'll
just we'll go through this, right? And we'll see. None of it
will actually be if you if you think this is relevant to her
testimony or her case, we'll just point out that just follow
Destiny's argument, okay? Negative character evidence. Oh, why
do I always forget it? Propensity evidence. Okay. Not admissible.
Warm up for Nick's later.
Oh god. I don't know if I can. Oh, that Nick. Okay, hold on.
Okay, hold on. We didn't end up talking.
Okay, we'll take a look. Real quick. Uh, yeah. Clarifying question
just cuz like I'm a bit out of the loop on all this drama. Am
I reading this correctly? Where she went on to Destiny's computer
without his consent while he was away and then looked at the
videos on his
lact, but she said she looked at videos. She looked at like DMs.
She took pictures of certain and then she she like saw those
videos and then just Oh, what what were the pictures of? Do people
have these pictures? Yes. That they were unconsensual. And then
what a tiny lie about now? We covered it earlier if you want
to go back. We're just watching the squad. The mod squad.
Did that legacy guy hop on call here before? Yeah, Legacy is
his roommate. I don't know. We'll see. I don't know what Legacy
is doing. How can Desi not have a password on his computer? I
don't know.
But Destiny did not give Abby consent to go on his computer and
look at these videos he took of other he's so Oh well given the
general culture of openness that Destiny participates in and
the fact that he didn't have a password on his computer. One
could almost argue that she might have had implied consent that
she was allowed to use his computer. I don't know one you know
one was a total piece of they might argue that. Not me. But you
know, if one was a total piece of they might argue that for a
sec, she's saying that Destiny sent her the video of Pixie
and Pixie saying that every time Destiny sent the video to somebody
else that was without what people Yeah. Why is he saying that?
He's just said that in a cadence that makes me think that he
thinks that's not true. The thing they're saying is that see
all the
drive that video and they're saying that what she did see seems
[__] I've seen all the drives and all the tapes of
everyone else. She saw stuff was when she saw stuff on Destiny's
computer that she snuck on that. So saying video it would have
been there because they're saying that posting. I see. I see.
I see. Thank you. Yeah, it's possibly. Yeah, it would appear.
So, okay. Anyway, you guys see his message thread. Oh, yeah.
So something like she said so she said she's seen all the drives
and all the tapes of everyone else too. I remember when she was
talking about all the tapes she was talking about it with being
on folders. Uh listen parseek I'll review this off stream and
I'll see if we still with each other. Okay. I don't know what
was said on here. We'll we'll check it out. We'll see on her
computer. I wouldn't I wouldn't go hard on the the the pest side
though. Okay. I personally if I were you just longterm advice
I use the she didn't say folders here but I remember her literally
telling me verbatim there was folders of like girls that he had
sex with on his computer also if you if you're saying that she
she was like taking pictures of like Molina's diary or whatever
like is she the one sending that around to people she was yeah
she's that was like that was like not months ago that was like
that was her or that was like someone else also was there a picture
of Molina's diary oh my god are we pretending we actually care
about Molina's privacy on this panel right Now I Hey, hold on.
I know somebody who actually violated Molia's priv privacy worse,
guys. Hey, Parseac, did you point out that Molina's uh consent
was far more like infinitely more egregiously violated by Destiny,
or were you too scared to do that on this panel in front of DG?
Hello? I can't tap my mic. Mr. Parac, are you still in chat?
Did you point that out there? Well, people were saying that there
was that was going around. Well, I think I think I think Well,
if it was, then yeah, that was Abby. That's just what Abby said.
We don't Well, no. Well, Abby, no. Abby was the one who did take
Oh, Parse. Wait, hold on. Parseek, you're totally unaware that
Destiny has sent non-consensual Molina to people like dozens
of times that she has literally actually had to call him out
that he has had to apologize it publicly on apologize for it
publicly on stream that he sent uh basically her pre- therapy
document where she wrote down like all of her trauma and stuff
to a bunch of random on Discord. Sorry, not e girls on Discord,
okay, that he'd never met before. And then I get to sit here
and watch uh I know this and this and this. We all know that.
And then they sit here and pretend, oh my god, this woman took
a picture of Molina's diary. And that's so offensive to me despite
me sitting here licking Destiny's balls all day. Or sending around
Destiny's Molina's diary. Like J at least had a copy of it that
he was like, "No, I didn't that was getting sent." Nope. That's
just a complete lie from this around that cuz it was definitely
her who did take a pictures of the diary and then uh after that
I found it through I think death or something and the diary is
completely disjoint as far as I know from the therapy document
right different things we all figured it out from there wasn't
Destiny the one sending stuff about Molina around he did but
I don't think he sent the picture of his diary sent the therapy
document which probably had even more egregious things in it
right obviously also non-conensually sent a ton of to people
like a ton.
Okay.
Like their therapy documents. It might have been, but I don't
know. It could have been it wasn't in the leaks, I think, but
I know for a fact of the word. Abby directly took a picture cuz
she mentioned it. I probably find it our direct if I look through.
But anyway, yeah, I don't really want to go through all this,
but yeah, pretty much TLDDR. I go through a conversation with
Abby. A lot of it's just her trying to like get me to talk about
her issues. If we're talking about the diary and therapy document,
I feel like Tim making Molina EP is relevant. Did you just want
me to read EP on stream here, Jacob? Or let's less about Destiny.
It's more just like she got she kind of like talks about how
she Guys, hold on. Wait. Let's not talk about Destiny's repeated
consent violations with regards to Molina. Let's talk about this
thing Abby did that was obviously wrong. Guys, we're really We
really need to narrow in, okay? Do not focus on the repeated
and egregious multiple consent violations from Destiny. Just
focus on this one picture from Abby, please. We got dragged into
things. We have to like go through each all these. There's a
lot of mess. Like look at all this. There's just like a lot of
text here and a lot of text is like unrelated. Uh so I don't
really know how to like go into this. A lot of it is even me
responding. It's just like or me like during the Destiny. So
I guess I'm like responding. But I think through these you should
go to the go find like the uh was like 60 70 messages in a row
or some [__] Yeah. Remember seeing that was insane.
Oh,
yeah. More messages. What up? Are you probably
It was It was It was It was the So, Holy [__]
I'm not meaning to hurt you. I'm ignorant. I am sorry. Do not
read when I message you and you won't call me. Ah, Darius said
this girl so that she didn't even like press charges when he
choked her out on Cam. God, what a guy. Okay, I don't know how
much further we're going. Okay, how much further do we have in
this segment before I cut it off? Still life or whatever. That's
sad. But I'm not going to go through him reading all of these.
you need to go back home. Like I can make sure you get a ticket
back home if this is like too much for you because I understand
like I'm not going to be in a relationship to you in any way,
shape or form. Like and I'm not going to continue like after
like I said the the the the stuff like we moved in in January.
It happened that month and then I think it happened like once
in February and then after that I literally did not engage with
her in any way, shape or form after that at all. And so she was
at the house for like 10 months after that without any stuff
going on. Feel like my analysis on this at the end was pretty
fair. If you didn't know the things I just mentioned, Parseek,
I'm not sure how it could be fair. Unless you just want to say
Abby made mistakes, right? Or I don't know. I think Legacy talks
about he thinks Abby committed like a crime against him, right?
Which is a totally separate issue. Could be true. I don't know
the the veracity of it. So, and then during that timeline, I
was like, "Hey, I understand this is like a weird thing because
I'm dating my ex. You don't like my ex. My ex likes to you. If
you need to go, if you need to leave, I can like make sure you
get a ticket back home or something like that." app. She's like,
"No, I'm a strong." She did this like LAR thing where she's like
thinks she's like like Ladybird or like some like weird like
indie film star and she's just like, "No, I'm too like I'm too
like strong. I'm like I'm strong. I can handle it." I don't know.
I need R to check DMs, but he's not checking DMs. So, got to
move this over for one second. Okay. I've gone through worth
my
Yeah. She would just talk about how her mom was like a crack
or something and I'd be like, "Okay, yeah,
J Parse on stream to discuss." Uh, possibly. But I I'm not really
looking to debate any of this. So reviewing,
but yeah. So yeah, know she just sent me a whole bunch of messages
and it's like uh wait, are we doing a talk sash? I want to see
that'd be dead. Yeah. Yeah. From I guess what I mean is like
um you keep the names from only if only in relation to a protective.
So yeah, my best guess was like either one of two things. The
first thing was that like this was drawn up a long time ago back
before the TTRO was issued and they just like worked on the assumption
that the TRO would go through which it didn't work. Either way,
the
TR is not good analysis at all. Yeah, this is Yeah, this is not
good.
It's not a protective order in general or a protective order
related to the plaintiff. It's a protective order related to
the people or the witnesses. Sure. So the the thing here is basically
the judge will probably comment on this in the hearing. Okay.
I assume that basically there's an exception for at least as
far as sanctions or reprimands go or based on um if you if you
could justify why you didn't comply with something, right? One
of the rules of civil procedure. And so you wouldn't even need
a protective order. You could just say, "Hey, we wanted these
people like, you know, protected under this seal." And I think
uh based on again we showed the the stuff from last night where
he went and leaked stuff about Abby immediately while that was
while the motion to seal was still pending. Uh it's why they
don't want identities revealed to Destiny while the the motions
are pending. Right. They they think he's like racing under the
wire to try to get these things out. Seems to be the case. Gotcha.
Okay. So it's different from Okay. Yeah. It it's just whole it's
just entirely nonsense. It doesn't make any sense. We could go
through the actual um like the back and forth on that premium
injection thing, but it might be a little too boring. But like
it just it doesn't make any sense. Um I I think I have the Destiny
and Pixie back and forth on the DACA, but yeah. All right, cool.
I we don't have to talk about this. Honestly, Parseek is not
new to the drama at all. I don't know why he's saying he is.
He's been in these communities the entire time. I literally saw
him in my community the entire time this thing was blowing up.
I don't if he says he wasn't watching any of it, I quite literally
don't believe him. But it's fine. Who knew that would be contagious?
Yeah, I I'm sorry. When Parex says he might not know the f like
the fine particulars of the case, like with regards to oh, a
motion for a TTRO or preliminary injunction, but like he knows
the broad strokes of the drama. I don't know why he would pretend
otherwise, but it's fine. It's fine. I understand you don't know
specifics. That's not what I'm saying. I'm saying that like probably
in terms of oh, Destiny shared Molina's revenge stuff like or
sorry, non-contentally shared Molina two people multiple times.
That's just like I feel like if you haven't seen that clip somewhere,
you have not watched any of this. Did you watch the Ryan Beard
video? There's no way you didn't watch the Ryan Beard video.
It's in there. Come on. Be honest, man. You watch somebody watch
a Ryan Beard video if you didn't watch it yourself. Be honest.
Just be honest. Just be be real. Okay, hold on. Where's Where's
our guy? Kelly's guy. I have a guy. Yeah. Yeah. There's one.
We test.